our new obsession bff meghan markle is
on the chair tonight like
how rad is this hollywood royalty and
actual royalty coming together
this is a dinner date i would like to go
on with you i know
i i feel like i'm like everyone's hold
up in my and what
montecito or santa barbara now yeah but
everyone i feel like our world has just
gotten so small
from through this whole pandemic and
everything seeing like even coming to an
event like this
and seeing people again and seeing the
same crew and the same familiar faces
and you're like my god
our world is so small like i miss you i
genuinely miss you
right like i miss being able to interact
with people and it's it's so funny
seeing that but like our little
yeah it's that's what makes me want to
get out the most is like
we need to see each other you need to go
up to montecito yeah like i didn't need
to go to montecito and chill in the
chicken house
i mean let's go archie's our cheese
chicken huh
yeah that's what it is yeah i was like
clucking hot either way i mean like a
fresh egg and a crispy teagan omelette
oh what a dream
they're so wonderful for for co-chairing
this and this is because this is like
obviously such an incredibly important
event that i'm so happy to be a part of
let's get this over with the best part
of my day
was when luna came out underneath the
skirt and she's very interested in this
do you think she wants my job
i i actually i think she might want to
be a publicist
oh really i think she is like she's
going for
she likes them mom you have to like turn
it this way this no don't say that she
she really watches what i say too thank
you so much i love you might be a good
publicist
she'll be a great publicist for you
here's my mom my grandma
they all have things maybe it'll be
cheaper
right it's quite the addition
[Music]
i don't even know the rest of the lyrics
i saw you and john on your way here
singing
it's so excited you get to see your
friends jlo i mean
why was it important for you to say yes
oh of course absolutely i mean we want
to
we want to tell people to get vaccinated
and simply like honestly this event
is just something to celebrate not only
these front line workers that are able
to come
see and watch this event but also to be
able to tell people to get this vaccine
and that it's safe and that it's
something that's going to
let us get back to our normal lives and
we can hug people again
and kiss and cook food and and have
brunch and do the silly things that we
miss
so much um you know it's a step towards
that then we just want people to get
vaccinated and get their second shots
and
all the things people aren't doing and
um i was so excited when i saw selena
was hosting it
because she is just so epic in the way
that she
will stand up for this like her voice is
not going unheard and it's so incredible
that she has such a huge huge following
and i'm so proud of selena i'm proud of
the rock everyone that's been
showing their that they that they got
the vaccine
they got the vaccination they need to
bring a banana bread for each other
i know some sort of chef cooking
situation
last thing you launched a new company
and kris jenner is your partner yes
it's called safely chrissy tegan you are
a genius
i'm a genius you're a teacher
i'm not bringing says what
i'm albert einstein i want to know what
the number one thing you've learned from
her because the ads were so funny
like what is the kris jenner lesson oh
god she's just such a boss
honestly it's like she's there for every
meeting she's on time she is early
she's early like and that's the thing
you don't want chris jenner waiting for
you
ever so that's honestly for me it's just
she just keeps me on my toes
like and i i just i live for her i love
her
the entire family
you